veamos si podemos aprender algo sobre
las cifras significativas también
llamados dígitos significativos la idea
detrás de esto es asegurarse de que
cuando hagamos un cálculo grande y
tengamos muchos dígitos como resultado
estos no representan una precisión mayor
de la que tenemos es decir que el
resultado no tenga más precisión que los
instrumentos que usamos para hacer las
mediciones antes de entrar en el tema y
ver cómo usar las cifras significativas
al calcular hagamos algunos ejemplos
para identificar las cifras
significativas y después trataremos de
deducir algunas reglas generales la
forma general de pensar en esto es qué
cantidad de dígitos realmente me están
dando información sobre cuán precisa es
mi medición entonces en esta primera
cantidad aquí las cifras significativas
son 700 entonces aquí tienes 3 cifras
significativas y podría hacerte sentir
un poco incómodo que no estemos
incluyendo estos ceros que están después
del punto decimal antes de este 7 que no
estemos incluyendo estos porque también
le ayudan a definir el número
es cierto pero no nos dicen cuan preciso
es nuestro cálculo para tratar de
entender esto un poco mejor
imagina que esto de aquí hubiera sido
medido en kilómetros
entonces si medimos 0.00 700 kilómetros
esto sería exactamente lo mismo que
7.000 metros tal vez de hecho sólo
usamos una regla que mide metros con
graduación en centímetros y dijimos que
son exactamente 7 puntos 0 0 metros
medimos al centímetro más cercano y
simplemente teníamos ganas de escribirlo
en kilómetros estos dos números son
exactamente lo mismo solo tienen
unidades diferentes pero creo que cuando
miras aquí tiene mucho más sentido
porque solo tienes tres cifras
significativas
estos ceros sólo cambian en función de
las unidades de medida que estás
utilizando pero los números que
realmente dan la precisión son el 7 el 0
y el 0 y la razón por la que estamos
contando estos ceros finales es porque
quien escribió este número no tenía que
anotar los pero los escribió para
indicar explícitamente que midió hasta
aquí
hubiera medido hasta aquí entonces se
hubiera omitido estos ceros los escribió
para decir explícitamente mira yo me di
hasta aquí si no hubiera medido hasta
aquí simplemente habría dejado estos
ceros fuera y nos habría dicho siete
metros
17.00 veamos el siguiente entonces con
base en la misma idea tenemos el 5 y el
2 los dígitos distintos de 0 serán
cifras significativas no incluimos este
0 inicial por la misma lógica de que si
esto fuera 0 puntos 0 52 kilómetros
sería lo mismo que 52 metros que
claramente sólo tiene dos cifras
significativas por lo tanto creo que
podemos decir que no debemos tomar en
cuenta los primeros ceros antes del
primer dígito distinto de cero
no queremos incluir esos si no todos los
dígitos distintos de cero y lo que haya
entre ellos y los ceros al final se
incluyen solo si hay un punto decimal
involucrado más adelante presentaré
estas ideas un poco más formalmente
entonces por aquí la persona calculó
hasta 370 y luego escribió el punto
decimal sí no
y era el punto decimal no estaría claro
cuán preciso fue pero debido a que
escribió el punto decimal significa que
lo midió exactamente hasta 370 no obtuvo
372 y luego lo redondeo hacia abajo o lo
aproximó al lugar más cercano a las
decenas este decimal te dice que los
tres son significativos así que aquí hay
tres cifras significativas luego en el
siguiente una vez más este punto decimal
nos dice que no sólo llegamos a la
unidad más cercana sino que también
colocamos otro cero al final lo que
significa que llegamos a la décima más
cercana así que en esta situación una
vez más tenemos tres cifras
significativas por aquí el 7 está en las
centenas pero la medida llegó hasta el
lugar de las milésimas y a pesar de que
hay ceros en el medio estos ceros son
parte de nuestra medición porque están
entre dígitos distintos de cero entonces
en esta situación todos estos dígitos
por la forma en que están escritos son
dígitos significativos aquí tienes seis
dígitos significativos
esta última es ambigua 37.000 no está
claro si esta persona me dio exactamente
hasta 37.000 tal vez me dio a la unidad
más cercana y obtuvo un número exacto
exactamente 37 mil o tal vez sólo me dio
a la unidad de millar más cercana así
que hay un poco de ambigüedad aquí si tú
ves algo escrito exactamente así y no
tuvieras más información dirías que sólo
hay dos cifras significativas o dígitos
significativos para que este número
fuera menos ambiguo quien lo escribió
podría haber puesto un punto decimal
justo allí y esto nos permitiría saber
que en realidad se trata de una
precisión de cinco dígitos que en
realidad tenemos cinco cifras
significativas entonces si no ves ese
punto decimal solo toma en cuenta 2